[Musique]
david testo travail aux 110 l'indoor
moringue boxe française
ici on fait aimer responsable de la
structure j'ai à tout ce qui est les
écoles lycées et aussi tous les
associations qui vient ici et aussi les
projets canada en dehors les projets
européens
les projets de la ligue les projets du
comité comme on en arrive là ne te
connais pas c'est pas le moment avait 23
ans 22 ans à l'époque
donc vous avez vu le mauvais c'était
lors d'un manifestation 20 décembre une
double face à apple et gastriques en
main et ça c'est le mauvais c'est un
sport traditionnel qui appartient la
réunion ne l'a commencée le morin avait
quand même on fait des besoins en
training à 3 et tous les sixièmes
atteindront travail était fait et après
le comité mouren le niveau à nous qu en
2000 n'avait pas ce moniteur en 2000 et
après l'aï la pose la première pierre j
versant lorrain et à partir de là me dit
et ça pose la première pierre minet
monitorat mouren c'est un l'occasion
pour - intègre à moins haut niveau dans
le fait qu eminem et cela m'a dit tu es
mon pass une pénible travail doit mettre
ça dans mon tête tous les invités d'une
telle interdiction est la définition du
moins que moi c'est de transmettre noté
l'héritage nous transmettre l'histoire
du transmis du patrimoine et nous la
transmettre le mouvement de l'année des
amas sur abc ce pigment tatamis du monde
et comme banana du salat vu le moral est
à ça c'est quoi ça et africains étaient
appelés à l'échelle rodrigues madagascar
maurice mozambique brésil et la chine la
france et n'a fait un petit sapin terme
et d'un pays noté parle de la réunion en
général voile à la réunion c'est ça nous
c'est mon enfant esclave
nous avons tenté des coups de fait les
orgies cette façon pour nous de nos
réseaux de transmettre notre héritage
pas à tout le monde
le mouren aujourd'hui la porter à
certaines personnes une association
sociale là d'autres jeunes et on est
intégré dans les associations ou en a
des contrats ou synthétiques intervenir
partout dans les écoles les associations
dans les centres et donc à travers ça ne
va plus crée aussi des mallettes
pédagogiques c'est-à-dire des livres des
cd avec des expos le moment il peut être
vu s'en est vraiment pratique et
techniquement par rapport les personnes
physiques se place donc maintenant on à
l'agrément ministériel dans les diplômes
maintenant il faut juste que notre
connaissance sur les pratiquants sur les
dirigeants pour faire en sorte que
demain matin mais ces jeunes là il peut
intégrer une collectivité et peu
intégrées et le rectorat y prend pas
nourri un produit comme en a besoin d'un
mouvement décembre bien dans ce moulin
kata kata kata date à la casse non il
faut prendre le bon marmaille un season
les fonds sont amis foncent me croise
est mauvais parce que même ça va des
chiens à faire il passa devant - nippon
à sa fin a fait avec donc m'imagine
l'avenir donc le bon marmaille vient d y
est là pas besoin d'habiter sens du bit
et ça ça me suis gay ça non drapron
salée avec 11 grave
banier à nice yoga